i want to talk about this week what
we've got coming up and what we can
expect and
i want to talk you know if we look back
at march right just the month of march
the two-year yield rose by 86 basis
points that's huge the 10-year yield
rose by 49 basis points the 30-year
yield rose by 27 basis points that's how
we got to that inversion that we've seen
right where two-year yields are paying
you more in interest than 10-year yields
are
and you saw a significant jump just to
kind of put those numbers in perspective
in march 2021 the two-year yield rose by
four basis points so a year ago the
two-year yield rose by four base points
and last month the two-year yield rose
by 86 basis points that is significant
that's a huge sell-off in the treasury
market particularly at the short end
those shorter dated bonds and that i
think is that's obviously why we're
seeing this inversion but it's also it
was something that had caused tech
stocks to sell off and folks to get
really worried about some of those
companies that weren't generating a lot
of profit
now it seems like those worries are gone
so we'll see if that continues because
the bond yields really shot up even
through march after that march 14th date
which i mentioned earlier on the live
stream was the death cross date and was
when you saw a lot of those tech stocks
bottom uh yields kept rising
but it seemed like everyone was okay the
stock market said oh that's fine um the
nasdaq continued to jump um and we're
going to see if we get back to all-time
highs now the dow is just 5.4 away from
its record uh probably a little closer
to that after we've risen in value today
the nasdaq is about 11 from its all-time
high and the s p is 5.2 percent from its
all-time high again coming into today so
we'll be a little close to those
all-time highs if we end in the green
and we'll see where we go i think the
biggest event coming up last week we had
huge data just you know overload right
this week not a ton of data the one
release i think you really need to make
sure you watch out for and it's it's not
something i think market investors are
typically used to digging through but
the release of the fomc minutes on
wednesday
we are going to get the minutes from the
fed's march meeting and we're going to
see what they really talked about what
was said uh you know what consensus was
drawn or maybe there wasn't consensus
here's why i think that's most important
powell usually comes out in the
post-meeting press conference and talks
about well here's what we said here's
what we determined and kind of really
lays it out there for the market he said
that the committee had an extensive
discussion on when it was going to begin
winding down the balance sheet
but he didn't get into it anymore so
what we'll get with those minutes is
what the committee really said about
winding down the balance sheet are we
going to get that in may are we going to
get that in june when they start to
reduce the fed's balance sheet it's
right now at about eight nine i'm going
on nine trillion dollars um it's about
doubled since where it was the beginning
of 2020. we've about doubled the balance
sheet and it's over eight trillion
dollars now when they start to wind that
down that means they're sucking money
out of the economy rather than
continuing to buy bonds and add to its
balance sheet the feds stopped buying
earlier this year and now they're going
to start letting some of those those
bonds that they've bought mature and
they're not going to buy new ones that
provides a lot of support for the
economy and the fed's saying that
they're going to stop pulling they're
going to kind of start to pull that back
so in addition to raising rates which
they've already said they're going to do
the market now pricing in 50 basis point
hikes at may in may and in june so
double the size the fed normally does we
could also find out that the fed is
planning to start balance sheet
reduction in may or june
so we've got double the size of a rate
hike that we normally get and we could
start to see balance sheet reduction is
the market prepared for that because the
fed has been incredibly accommodative
keeping rates really low
now they're starting to pull that back
and in addition to potentially a 50
basis point rate 50 basis point rate
hike which the market is pricing in
which investors seeing goldman sachs
deutsche bank they've all come out and
said yeah we expect 50 basis point 50
basis point hikes at the next two
meetings
potentially as many as the next four
meetings
and we could see balance sheet runoff
which is basically they've the fed has
said that would act as kind of another
basis point or another 25 basis point
hike so we could start to see some very
significant tightening of rates from the
federal reserve uh starting as soon as
may and those minutes that we're going
to get on february is going to really
tell us are really going to tell us what
to expect and whether that's really in
the cards
the other big release i think you should
be watching for next week is going to be
the fed's g19 report on consumer credit
this is a real nerds report and i know a
lot of people don't really get into this
but
it'll be great to check the temperature
on consumer credit right before the fed
really starts to actually raise rates
we've only had one rate hike so far this
year
once we get into may and june credit
card rates are really going to start to
shoot up
and we'll see what consumers react to
that so it'll be great to have a
baseline for did consumers continue
because we've seen a lot more putting
things on credit cards a lot more
revolving credit which is those credit
cards and things like that so check out
the fed's g19 report that's coming on
tuesday also we've got fed speak this
week fed governor lail brainerd is going
to be speaking as well as new york fed
president john williams behind powell i
think those are the two most significant
fed speakers lail brainerd she is
expected to be number two the vice chair
uh if she's confirmed by the senate so
unofficially but soon to be expected to
be soon officially the number two and
then the president of new york fed is
always a significant member of the rate
setting committee so always someone to
watch new york fed president john
williams is going to be speaking um
so we are now in a new month and a new
quarter and we're going to find out if
these trends continue so far we saw
stocks rise a little bit on friday we
are seeing a pretty significant pickup
in stocks right now in particular the
nasdaq is up significantly right now
checking in on where it is uh the nasdaq
up 1.76
so it seems like as the day continues
stocks rising further um and and that
you know we'll see does that continue do
we keep on the pattern that we were on
from march 14th where stocks went up and
tech stocks have outperformed or do we
continue on the plat on the path that we
were on before that um and stocks go
down and stocks have a rough time and
oil prices do really well again this is
our our live stream we are coming to the
end of it right now so i want to thank
you guys for being with